صوره المشهد في مدينه انطاكيا
حيث الدمار في كل مكان
والعمارات المدمره والبنايات العائله
للسقوط
مع ان اعمال
رفع الانقاذ تتواصل هذا البناء الذي
نتواجد فيه والابنيه المجاوره معظمها تم
اكتمال اعمال البحث فيها واخرجت جميع
الجثث التي كانت تحت الانقاض
وبقيت بقي فقط الركام في هذه المناطق نحن
في وسط مدينه انطاكيا مركز محافظه هاتاي
الدمار مهول جدا البنايات العائله للسقوط
اكثر من البنايات المدمره في اي لحظه انا
اقف امام عماره سكنيه مائله تماما وهي
مكونه من سته طوابق مائله تماما في اي
لحظه ممكن ان تسقط بحسب البيئه تحدثت انها
عاينت
29,300 بنايه في مدينه
هاتاي حتى الان قالت ان هناك سته الاف
وثلاث مئه من هذه البنايات هي يجب ازالتها
مشهد هاتاي مشهد انطاكيا ومختلف تماما عن
بقيه المشاهد الدمار فيها اوسع
الاصابات فيها اكثر والوفيات فيها اكثر
وهذا ينبع عن صعوبه الاعمال والاعمال
تتضاءل باخراج ناجين من تحت الانقاض